it was impossible it was like he was
gonna have to roll a one in a hundred
at disadvantage he rolls two twenties
both nat twenties he rolled double that
twenties
at this advantage throwing a rock into a
hole
with magical darkness against this
fleeing black dragon i had to give him
the hit
the whole table was screaming
you know there's no way he could hit it
he hit it and he killed that dragon
hi i'm joe manganiello and this is
dungeons and dragon support
[Music]
okay this is from silk the crocker
aka crocs fans only hey people who play
dundas and dragons out there
what's the best way to start slash learn
slash get into it well i think there's
two ways you can go
one you can get three books you need
three books to play d and d
you need the players handbook you need
the dungeon masters guide and you need a
monster manual
from there it's pretty self-explanatory
make a character
you're going to get between 50 and 70
of how to play d and d or at least all
the necessary questions you're going to
want to ask
from creating a character so crack a
player's handbook pick a race pick a
class
pick your background get your equipment
set your character up
then from there somebody's going to need
to run the game so if you're ambitious
you love storytelling the way that i do
you're going to lean into becoming the
dungeon master
rather than a player now dungeon masters
you're going to want to read the dungeon
masters guide get acquainted with the
monster manual see what monsters in
there you like you don't you want to
throw at your characters blah blah blah
then you're going to want to either home
brew an adventure which means you write
your
own or the other option i would say that
just simplifies things
is to get the starter kit which is a
boxed set and everything once again is
self-explanatory
but it's on a smaller scale that's how
you get into it brother
oh the next question is from my buddy
sam witwer dungeons and dragons question
what's a more dangerous character to
have in your party lawful evil
or chaotic evil it's a great question
sam and one
that i feel like i am uniquely qualified
to answer
i would say the better thing for the
party
would be a lawful evil character because
at least there are rules there are
collective goals that can be adhered to
you might have
a you know dragonborn worshipper of
tiamat
in your group uh who plays really well
with the group and there's a collective
goal
but there's also because of the lawful
evil there's a
kind of a long play goal there's a goal
outside of the
group that this dragonborn paladin of
tiamat would be also attempting to
achieve
but they can play nice within a group
it's kind of like when magneto
came to take over the x-men after
charles xavier died and they could see
eye to eye and a common goal
but you got to watch out once you start
achieving that goal because that lawful
evil character might flip
chaotic evil on the other hand chaotic
just doesn't play nice i've been in
groups
chaotic players have dungeon master
progressive chaotic players it's like a
great having a gremlin in your group
that's just going to throw a monkey
wrench everywhere you go
so i think that that would be a lot more
frustrating you'd want to kill them or
throw them out
next one is from star shinobi good
morning or afternoon evening depending
on where you live question
for today what was your favorite way a
gm
has a game master has opened a campaign
or one shot we've all woken up in a cell
or we're sitting in a tavern but have
you had anything unique i'm interested
yes my friend john castle
ran us through this adventure where we
were unconscious and we
all woke up didn't know where we were
had no armor no weapons
and we were all realized we were chained
to each other on
a slave barge so we all had to kind of
wake up
and then decide what to do and i was
playing a minotaur
so i started like headbutting our
captors off the barge
into the water and now we were fighting
and kind of chained up and he created
these cool mechanics for us being
chained up and how that worked and
how we could try to break the chains or
you know work together
or how much we could move or not move
and i just thought it was really
ingenious and a very very smart way of
starting out
and then we had to like the guys we
killed they're you know subdued we had
that then those became our weapons so we
were just trying to piece together
anything we could
get to keep fighting and get off of this
barge and and fight for freedom so
that that was a cool one just you know
off the cuff okay mariah sanchez
aka mariah in reality
tips for a first-time dungeon master a
dungeon master is a storyteller you're a
showrunner
of a long-form narrative that's going to
take place over
months and maybe years so you always
want to be
you know all the you know few steps down
the road understanding
how to set up these character arcs these
story arcs
that have payoffs down the line so with
that said
you know what are your arcs what's going
to be satisfying to your players and
that's going to differ for every group
so a dungeon master also has to have the
type of
chess like approach to storytelling
where you're building these
tracks out ahead you know your 3 10
moves
chess moves ahead on the board from your
players but you're also going to have to
be empathetic to the point where you can
understand you can look into the heart
of your players and understand what each
one of them wants from the game
some want to hunt for treasure some want
to cause chaos
mythology and deities and and kind of
religion
and magic and deep dive storytelling so
you kind of want to gauge
how your players are or what they like
then you're going to mold that story and
be able to
use those archetypical qualities in
order to build
you know stories and throw things at
them you know it's a dungeon master have
fun
understand your players and prep because
inevitably
your players are never going to go where
you think they're going to go they're
going to choose their own
crazy narrative they're going to kill
the shopkeeper that you
wanted to have become part of their
group and this great storyline they're
just going to murder him and steal all
of his stuff so you need to be ready for
all of that
in the moment and along with prep i
would say
keep lists post-it notes on the inside
of your dungeon master shield with
names on them just tons of names male
names female names human names dwarven
names elven names just
because you're gonna have to be pulling
those out of your ass
way more than you could ever possibly
imagine
so that's another uh probably the fourth
big key to being a dungeon master just
be
ready to pull it out of your ass that
gets into like listening to your own
inspiration
wherever you want the story to go or you
get an inspiration to take it just take
it there just go there
all right this is from turk owl
that is a dragon's question do rogues
get to attack twice per action
if they have daggers in both hands kind
of lost on this logistic all right
that's an interesting question yeah
i can see how that would be confusing
there's a fighting style
where you can you can have a second
attack
and there is a feat in which
you get to add your damage bonus to
attacks or off hand attacks
so you know you either need the fighting
ability or you need a
feat that allows you to strike with two
hands
we're talking daggers here so we're
talking about a small weapon rather than
a large weapon which gets into a whole
other thing because there are feats of
war fighters in which they can carry
you know heavy weapons in both hands
this is from at
optional rule i break his knees in
quotations
many a d d or tabletop role-playing game
game master looks on in horror as the
players torture someone who doesn't do
what they want
how do you handle this in your games do
you overlook it
penalize them encourage them hey i'm
just the referee
i just set up the world i'm just the the
voyeur i mean
don't get me wrong i'm also the
architect of the
long form story so i'm the one who's
setting the the tracks down
you can gently nudge people into
storylines that you think are going to
be really interesting but inevitably
it's up to them because they may decide
to go the other way so you need to be
ready for that
and with that said the beauty of role
playing
is that you can do whatever you want if
they want to kill and torture the
shopkeeper
they can do that they can do whatever
they want so they're going to start with
the shopkeeper but then they're going to
take out the sheriff and his deputy when
they get there and then they're going to
take over this town and hold them
hostage
i always get excited whatever the
players do because i'm just going to go
with it
you know my players sometimes come
across
hill giants in the wild and a fight
breaks out and they kill all the hill
giants
and then when they go and they search
the bodies of the hill giants
i'll say yes um it's interesting you
hear something making a noise
in the pocket of the hill giant's vest
you look inside of the
you know the vest pouch and it's like a
little
bone rattle that looks like it would fit
into the hand of a
of a baby hill giant oh and what's this
it's a it's a taxidermied fox that's
been stuffed like a
like a child's toy somewhere off in the
distance you
swear you hear the the faint sound of a
baby crying
you know so it's like you just wiped out
a whole village of hill giants
and you think yeah we did it and now i'm
gonna make you feel bad because you left
all these like orphaned hill giant
babies out there screaming in the night
so it's like i always try to make
my players feel bad about wiping things
out because there's so much just
head chomping off and lighting people on
fire in d
d that a lot of times the humanitarian
angle never gets covered you know but
that's kind of the sense of humor that i
have of my players you know like i said
man it's just have fun with it
let it go it's it's not up to you it's
up to them and then you just start
guiding it where you want it to go
because yeah ultimately as the referee
you can be as hard on them as you want
or not depending on how you feel
or you know whatever parabasis next
dungeons and dragons
question what was your favorite
character class and race
growing up i was big in the elves
because elves had a little bit of magic
and a little bit of fighting and i
really like them 2e
dragon lance i i was a minotaur the
second you could be a minotaur i was a
minotaur of course
and now when i say elf i'm not trying to
get out of answering what's my favorite
class back in the day
elf was race and class you were an elf
which means you had you had both which
is kind of interesting
i love playing a warlock i'm playing a
warlock right now in a mad mage
dungeon the mad mage campaign and man
there's just so many tricks up their
sleeves so
for me i love playing
characters that have tons of options
like i have a
high level sorcerer that i love playing
because along with the meta magic
and then you really have tons of options
you know and ways to get out of
situations or ways to be creative or
ways to participate in the storytelling
you know if you
twin polymorph t-rexes inside of a
tavern
doesn't matter what the dungeon master
had planned you're in charge now
of the story you know you just caused
this to happen so
i really like being able to really
affect the story and i find that those
spell casters there's a lot of
wow factor okay this is from
j jlj f legere
aka geekbot question is
is it weird that i practice character
voices in front of the bathroom mirror
no i don't think that's weird i don't do
a character voice too much when i'm
a player unless i'm like delivering some
opus or
some charisma check but when i dungeon
master i i it's his voice is all over
the place
all my npcs have voices whether they're
yeah the lady sweet little
lady works don at the uh at the
apothecary your name's tony you know
weigh-ins want what can i get ins that's
basically the pittsburgh dialect where i
grew up so
you know and then my brother will start
laughing people have been in pittsburgh
will start laughing people even who
haven't benefits from start laughing
because it's such a rich character and
it's based
on somebody who works at a sandwich shop
back home you know that i know and then
they become a character and then
ian she gavrin um see my nephew donnie
in that he's a blacksmith
you know and then they go and visit
donnie he talks the same way you know or
like you know all of the animal
familiars or you know the druids
speaking animals then there's there's
all of those voices
you know of all of the like the
christmas the christmas animals in south
park
you know if they talk to a squirrel the
squirrel talks like the hat
of course and then they want to talk to
the horse and the horse
oh they went that way or they talked to
a seagull
but the seagull wasn't impressed at all
with what they were doing
even in fact he was he was amazed any of
them wound up alive
uh how sloppy they were and uh they
asked to seek all you know what's your
name
you can call me christopher squaken i
think you should take it a step further
and film yourself doing the character
voices that way you could critique your
performance
i don't know maybe there's some sort of
career for you here you're going to
become an actor or something but no man
that's that i totally do all of that i
i always develop voices or i figured a
voice out and then
make a note to myself somewhere down the
line i need a character
that's going to talk like ted knight in
caddyshack
you know and then when they get to the
council's oh hello hmm yes
that's usually how my dm'ing goes as
well so
i identify i just pivot from voices but
you can see that it's just
it's endless i'm always making notes of
this voice or that voice and
uh you know and popping those characters
up along the way seragushi
underscore arts what would be a fearsome
and evil
name for a black dragon and what kind of
a gem would you give him
good question so i actually just
answered this question
so i designed a quest book for the
relaunch
of hero quest i named the black dragon
venom v-e-n-i-m
which i like she should take that and i
would think i don't know
for a gem i would give the black dragon
a giant
amethyst some gigantic huge massive
amethyst that had some sort of like even
in darkness had some sort of like
magical
ability to to create light from the
inside almost like a pulsing but it's
just the way that the light shifts and
hits it but even in the dark you can see
the light sparkling inside somehow it's
got its own
kind of thing going on anyway there you
go this is from one crit wonder
what is your favorite d d campaign
setting and why
i love dragon lance i just do i like
crin
i like that there are books that are
companions that give you a fully fleshed
out
view of the world because i find that
with some of the other worlds it's very
hard to get the canon straight
and it's very hard to understand you
know
pantheons and gods and it just seems
like there's so much catch-up work and
there are all
answers to these questions but it's like
so hard to find them and there's
different answers to
different questions anyway with crin if
you
don't include the fifth age stuff that
was done without margaret and tracy if
you only
look at the margaret and tracy cannon or
at least you know the books that they
you know okayed you get this rick really
beautiful amazing deep
world that involves all the things about
fantasy that i like
which is you know fighting and
friendship and family
and romance and love my gosh it just
seems like they're trying to eradicate
romance from from d
and d and tabletop and so i really love
dragon lance for that reason it's it's
very human
and you understand the gods you
understand what's at stake and there are
great
npcs and villains and things and you
know my favorite
you know characters in all of d and d
cannon so i
like dragon lands i like crin um
recently i've gone into collecting all
the old dark sun
modules and and box sets so um those are
starting to pile up so maybe over the
holidays i'll be able to
dive into those okay this is from matt
holmes aka
table top payton if your pc's philosophy
differs from the rest of the group do
you roll up a new one
conform to the group or see how much you
can get away with behind their backs
you're trying to make me an accomplice
or somehow justify you
destroying your party uh play nice young
man
don't be a menace to your own group you
know or
something where like somebody's gonna
want to punch you on the way up the
stairs because i've had players that try
to split the party
and that becomes their thing i'm gonna
go explore and some character dies
people get pissed and they have words
with each other about it so
you know it's a team game play nice with
other kids in the sandbox
but with that said like don't let that
get in the way of
of a great character all right this is
from edward r
curtis aka dimly underscore
lit it's very gothic odd dungeons and
dragons question
typically when making your player
character do you come up with the
character first
then the race class stuff or the other
way around
choosing the race class stuff then
making a character around that
interesting question um i think it
differs i think it just differs from
character to character
when i was a kid we didn't have
dragonborns those came around in fourth
edition
and i wasn't playing that was on a dnd
hiatus doing like third and fourth
edition so when i met back up with fifth
edition and i saw that you could play as
a dragonborn
and then i saw that they were chromatic
i thought oh man that's like playing
a low level you know or aspiring dragon
highlord or someone in the
dragon army in dragonlance in the
dragonlance books and i just thought man
that is like
super cool we didn't have like i said we
didn't have that when i was a kid so i
naturally gravitated towards
picking a red dragonborn first i liked
paladins
i i thought paladin was a you know
really cool class growing up
and a little bit of magic lots of
fighting then i saw
that there was a possibility of playing
an oath breaker if your dungeon master
allowed it
so that's how i built that character
archon yeah and then other times it's
like i already know what the character
is you know he's going to be a little
halfling who has
all black leather and a [ __ ] mask and he
walks around
and talks like this and he you know and
he's a wild sorcerer because every time
he shoots magic he doesn't know what's
going to happen
and you know and you know so all of a
sudden now i have this little like
german s m halfling
wild sorcerer that i just cooked up in
my brain and
all right i'll make that character and
play them okay the next one is from the
danwood
spiral i if that's a nine inch nails
reference
then that's awesome currently making
some homebrew races for my own d d
setting any abstract ideas weird is good
i don't know man i always thought about
like you know a civilization of dark
gnomes
i have all kinds of other ideas that i
use you know in my game and float around
i mean i'll give you one i wanted
something between
dragon and draconian because i you know
i have the fifth edition draconian stats
don't tell anyone so i wanted something
in the middle there kind of like a tank
that could move in and so i created
these abominations and created a
storyline of how they were being created
and then i just stated them up and you
know throw them at my players
okay next question is from yum diem when
a character dies
and the player makes up a new character
what level do you start them at
in old older versions of d d first
edition second edition basic
you had characters in a party that were
all different levels because the game
was really
centered upon getting your character at
the highest
level it could possibly go getting your
character the best magical items the
most
gold cetera you had players in the party
you could have a ninth level player with
a first level player with a second level
player
whereas in fifth edition it is more
centered around the collective story
that you're telling
all the characters in the group go up at
once you don't have characters going up
on different levels generally so you
know when a character dies
jumps back in and you might play it
differently but all my characters are
all at the same level
they all move from fourth to fifth level
together from fifth level six level
together so it's easy you just jump them
back in at that level
but it's dm's choice a dungeon magic can
do anything if you think it's better
storytelling wise to start somebody off
at level one
while the rest of the group is advanced
like go for it like that's that's
totally fine
okay this is from at trash mob minis
maybe a dumb question there's no dumb
questions but i'm a dumb dm
okay how do i get the players to form
bonds between their characters
is this a chemistry that happens at its
own pace or is there something i can do
to catalyze connections good question
there's always a narrative story element
that can tie characters together whether
they came from the same place or they
start having the same dreams
and start relating that to each other
that somehow are tied
they might have been somewhere at the
same time but you can
text them both separately in between
sessions and let them know that there's
this part of their backstory there's
this part of their backstory but the
other thing is is like
yeah i mean i think it's just gonna
happen you know i had a character who
was a bear barbarian
and he was just used to taking all the
punishing damage and soaking that up
but there was a cleric in the group and
the cleric this guy was amazing
he would keep it's my friend jason lyles
he would keep track
of what everyone's hit points were
everyone in the group
and he was like the greatest cleric i've
ever played with and he knew how many
hit points i had as the barbarian in his
job he would keep
feeding me healing so my character's job
was to soak up all the damage
and make sure everybody attacked him and
it was this really great symbiotic
relationship that we formed that then
became like the story line where
on a role-playing sense my barbarian
character had done a lot of things that
he regretted
and there he was this like holy
pious character who believed in this god
and believed that the god could save
my my character soul there became this
storyline between the born out of the
characters out of the both of them where
um they kind of needed each other and
fed off of each other you know
it's really cool when that stuff happens
so you know but there's only so much of
it that you can force upon your players
at oregon rolled a 20 what is your best
d d memory um probably
comes from a couple of years ago right
around the holidays
close to my birthday my wife there was
this big box
next to the front door she told me to go
bring the box into the kitchen and i did
and i
opened it and unbeknownst to me sophia
had had
someone at within d d connect her to
jeff
easley who painted all the cover
paintings for the old players handbooks
and dungeon masters guides and adventure
modules he's one of the four horsemen
just
you know one of the great great great
fantasy painters of all time
and um she got in contact with him and
had him
paint my arkhan the cruel my
my my dragonborn oathbreaker paladin of
teammate she surprised me with
this original jeff easley painting of
archon
in front of tmat like it was the cover
of one of those old books
but you know to be honest like there's
there's a great d d memory every week in
our games
that's kind of the beauty of it
something unexpected happens every week
all right so that's it from me joe
manganiello
i want to thank the
amazing artists and storytellers and
writers dundas and dragons was really a
fountainhead of creativity for me as a
kid
is where i learned how to build a
character
build a backstory where i learned
long-form
storytelling as it pertains to writing
and producing
and directing and really just sparked my
lifelong love of telling stories so
thank you so much for your questions i
had a blast
answering them and i hope we get to do
it again someday thanks a lot